hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village
i just gotta consult something real
quick here
[Music]
all right okay good now that that's done
and out of the way let's go find out how
we kill a fish
i don't really know how but my last name
is fishbach
well i don't know and i was in the
middle of a bit there ethan
okay my last name's fishbox so i assume
i know about
fish a little bit but shut up not funny
anymore
that's probably fine it doesn't seem too
normal or abnormal
is this a puzzle is this a puzzle
i think that this is a puzzle okay
is that a blue or green up top right
that's kind of hard to tell
uh
who the hell is unzipping their pants to
my right
i'm gonna pretend like i didn't just
hear that
hello oh
what the hell why were you unzipping my
dude what were you
how did you get there the hell
hi yeah okay this is normal you wish to
make a purchase
i wish to know how the hell you got
there but i guess you're not gonna
tell me so whatever uh i can make this
health increases permanently although i
could make
damage okay let's assume that i no i
don't have enough poultry okay let's
might as well do this
hardly wait just excuse me a moment all
right
here it is please join me okay
uh sure now my health has been increased
not that i'll ever be able to notice it
i wouldn't mind having that again too
bad i can't do that for you
okay um all right cool odd times ethan
what do you mean hard times
what you don't want it shut up shut up
if i say so myself no one asks you and i
gotta go find something first
i'm sure there's secrets back here the
outhouse of course
yeah how does that guy go to the
bathroom do i even want to know that
maybe he's going to the bathroom
constantly that's awfully convenient
what a pleasant thought all right let's
try this
if i can drain the water
uh-huh [ __ ] there's no power you're
right there's no power
but there's a thing here and i gotta
turn on the electricity for the sluice
gate
okay so am i supposed to do something
about this yeah
fine i also need to craft up some uh
more amro i really do not have as much
as i thought i did
it's probably better to get shotgun ammo
than anything
just because i say so and i
when i say something it means that it's
true where
does this path lead
how did this truck get here how's
anything get here this crank is old and
busted up
it feels like it's going to snap at any
second i hope it doesn't break the only
other one we have is over at windmill 2.
windmill 2 what do you mean windmill 2
i don't even know where windmill 1 is is
this going to break i bet it's going to
break because it's all busted up right
it's gonna break it's gonna break where
am i going what am i doing
i knew it
well seriously well i mean i knew that
was gonna happen it's not like it was a
surprise but
whatever freak out man okay that looks
sliceable
knife is weaker than i thought it was um
okay so i guess i go down the ladder
no one say anything no one say anything
all right how do i get over to windmill
to did i miss anything i'm missing stuff
aren't i
oh well don't matter fish don't eat me
fish man why can't i eat these fish
what did i get what could have possibly
been among the fish
hey yeah hi yeah thank you
all right well that goes over there but
is there anything else that i need
probably
all right i'm gonna go for it don't eat
brief his friend
i'm not looking for fish food yeah me
neither i mean i'm not i mean
we're i'm you so yes
hi bud you could not do that
how close was i to death right there i
feel like i was very
yeah i was probably very close
okay bud okay what did i do what did i
do
i did nothing oh
i can barely follow him he's moving too
fast
oh my god are you done i need this to
fall but how
so there's something here there's
something here
well why did i why i feel like i just
died
i don't see another yellow there so it
seems like that's just hanging on by a
thread but it's still not
falling unless i gotta like shoot it
yeah all right i'ma head back
stop my head back i do not see any other
yellow
i don't know how you're doing that that
doesn't make any sense
all right fine that doesn't make sense
but i'll go around it's fine
oh there i see the yellow point and
well is it even worth it now i gotta go
all the way back how did i miss that
oh oh
i'm fine
hello hi how are you doing wham
280 really that's it that's all you're
going to give me
chompus change chomp has changed
oh yeah i don't mind if i do
these are really convenient these are
like
oh never mind that wasn't convenient at
all yeah that didn't help me at all
what was that supposed to do hello okay
how do i get over to that
that's the question is there like
another way
up to all this stuff probably
yeah kind of stanky yeah that's kind of
gross that's kind of disgusting
that's kind of disgusting i mean
that ain't right oh wow that's
convenient okay thank you for that
uh oh you put up another cart too thank
you that's
whoa well blue now is good
this seems unnecessary this seems
incredibly unnecessary and overly
complicated for something that seems to
just be natural flooding
but you're trying to tell me that this
is all cool
oh oh it's
timed oh i see come on come on
come on come here come here oh no no no
you stay up you stay up okay good
good yeah this is totally normal oh
ms i gonna get a magnum mites i have
already about a chance to get a magnum
did i miss a magnum somewhere
for my magnum dong
oh wait wait god damn it oh i missed my
chance bro okay here we go here we go
i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it
doing it no
don't eat me
he didn't listen to me okay chunkers
trunks
chunkis trunks trunks
trunks okay i chunked this i
chunky-sized it
well hi friend
going now i'm going now i'm good
me i'm the goodest
watch you uh yeah mama and mama ain't
impressed my dude
mama ain't too happy with your
performance
all right why did i come over here why
did i throw him oh
okay good job there
oh yeah you'll get me next time oh
you'll eat me up
real good oh yeah i'm looking forward to
it
oh yeah you're going to teach me a
lesson
yeah maybe if you weren't so actually
disgusting
you might impress mama a bit more okay
now lady dimitrescu's someone that you
should draw inspiration from
now that she was something special
she she really was
[Music]
she was really something special
anyway you'll never live up to her
you'll never live up to her
never ever so don't even bother just
give up already
why even try
i caught myself a big one even you're so
funny you so [ __ ]
funny he's so funny man
he's so funny
oh god okay yeah i do okay wait no come
on
come on
me thinks that would just sink the boat
but apparently not
all right i made it
did i miss anything good
can i get a light ah my eyeballs will do
the work
uh jump i guess
oh oh convenient
and all this for a freaking crankshaft
at least i'll be able to use it on the
all the other crankshaft things
that's what it's all about multiple uses
oh yeah what are you trying to do man
what are you trying to do
because whatever it is you're not doing
it very well
nice nice nice what is this
can't climb it up like this
are you sure about that
oh is that crazy or was there yellow on
oh
oh oh yes there is yes there
is yellow on that yes there
is yellow on that okay
so oh all right
well i guess i can't go back okay
if i was thunkling about this
it would be something where i have to
get
that piece of windmill to be a ladder
for this right that's what i clearly
have to do
so how would i get that thing off of
that
other than just blowing it up because
that's really my first instinct is just
to blow it
if you could stop slapping the side of
this
for two seconds i would be able to think
properly
but there is definitely most
certainly a way
that i the genius gamer that i am
would be able to cause this to do
exactly what i needed to do bang
what happened okay it's not
shooting it what about him hitting
things
would that have an impact in some way
okay i'm actually cranking this then i
mean i pulled it off of there i could
have just cranked it
first but now i cranked it
oh i don't know how that works but hey
fine by me i tried cranking it before
that that was why i didn't think of that
again because i already went up to and i
pressed f
i slapped my use button all over it and
it just
didn't do nothing okay
oh yeah
nice nice my dude nice oh thank goodness
he finally stopped
cronkite chancellor cronkite channel
cronkite chunker i don't know why i'm
doing this but i
am a crunk of a chunkler
okay okay
okay we got power my dudes
we got some really sick slopping chicken
hey duke you miss me buddy
you miss me pal you miss me why don't
you sell more bullets my man
why don't you sell more bullets probably
because i would buy all the bullets
i eventually i'm gonna have to get that
gun again because
well it's another gun and i don't have
enough gun
although if i do get the magnum i'm just
gonna go with that adventure
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
what's this about
okay i know the thing
white no
no come on go right jesus
oh that one's just that was just broken
what are you talking about oh weird oh
oh it's oh
it's upside down oh
i see okay interesting okay
very interesting okay very very
interesting actually
so then this is there we go got it
nailed it it was crooky wookie
i probably shouldn't put too much stress
on that cut off hand you know the bones
hey sorry buddy got it you're about to
be sluiced
uh well like
yeah yeah all right you're all right
buddy you okay buddy
hey buddy you okay buddy
hey buddy all right pal
okay buddy you have a good one buddy
yeah i'm sure i'm getting a lot of money
i don't exactly know what to do with all
the money but i sure am getting a lot of
it
uh october 1 a sunny day mother miranda
brought me
five peoples from the village just like
i asked it i made them sleep with some
liquid and then i put
caddo in their tummies i am looking
forward to the cadu to grow in their
tummies
october 2 a cloudy day four of the
people from the village are dead this
morning
one is almost a lichen i sent it to my
lab on the mountain i failed again
mother wants strong vessels but i cannot
get any
i fee will need more people from the
village
okay oh oh my
oh oh my
well looks like i might just
have to switch out after all
time to say goodbye to the old and bring
in the new
hi diddly ho how's it go you know i
didn't think that i would actually like
have as much inventory space as i do but
i seem to have quite a bit extra
which is a little odd yeah whatever
when am i gonna give that magnum they
gave me the ammo for it i would have
thought that i would have
had a chance to get the gun itself
beforehand but
i'm assuming i'm just dumb and missed
something
which is the more likely outcome oh
hello
you seem to be equipping me for
something what would this something be
uh-huh i guess i gotta do this
okay what if i do
whoa yeah that kind of sucked
okay
yeah you don't like that do you yeah you
don't like that do you
yeah you don't like that do you okay
come here come here come here come here
come here oh
let's talk about this before i'm too
close to this and kaboom
don't look at you what way how are you
not looking at me you have so many eyes
thank you for all the supplies this is
love oh minds yes
actually let's put this uh oh god okay
let's not walk over that
i'm the reason
[Music]
oh gross what are you about to do oh
my god don't be saving oh i need to be
oh god oh yeah no that's not
good oh my god
don't save that one
oh that's that's not good uh
hi bud how you doing
can you come this way so i can blow you
the hell up i've got
two splodies here just for you
yep that's oh i don't like your belly
oh i do not like your belly i'm gonna
shortcut this to four
oh well that's not good oh oh
really oh you [ __ ]
come this way come this way
that's what i thought
ow what the hell what was that
come here come here you no don't no no
can't get caught
[Music]
am i safe here really doesn't feel like
i'm in enough
i guess i'm in enough
uh excuse me i gotta you know make some
stuff it's pardon
pardon me excuse me pardon me
okay my land mine's over here my dude
what is that sound
this way thank you how about another
come this way
oh are you are you done
oh i see you i see you oh oh oh oh
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh yeah
okay
okay okay yeah this way bud
easy
well
oh and death as he was in life
disgusting yeah pretty much but can you
blame him
yes absolutely you can blame him i blame
him for everything
well good job everybody you really
cheered me on through that i couldn't
have done it without you
i absolutely could have done it without
you but i'm saying this to make you feel
better to try to coerce you
into liking this video and maybe
subscribing and commenting because
that's what youtube's all about it's
called reverse psychology because i'm
telling you this openly you don't know
anymore whether you should trust me or
not
so your liking and commenting is kind of
like in a flux situation if you do it
because i said to do it then you just
did what i said to do but if you don't
do it
because this might be reverse psychology
then what are you gonna do
you don't know what to do it's
completely indifferent
knew you'd do it or not whatever you did
i knew that would happen
maybe bam when am i gonna get a magnum
when when am i gonna get a magnet i
yearn for the magnum don't we all
don't we oh hey it's his house ah
this nerd mother miranda gave me a rose
jar no one likes me which is why i
thought they would leave me out again
but heisenberg said that was why we each
get a rose
the ceremony cannot happen without us
all there mother didn't seem to care
though
mother said rose is a vessel with a
vessel mother can get back her real
child back
even though she has been dead for a very
long time but if mother does then
what will happen to me i'm not a real
child will she abandon me
no i don't want that
whatever i do not have any sympathy for
you
how is there another key all right
my guess
okay there you go
you're better off than i thought who's
that
oh come on we just met a while back
nothing really matters
you're the last [ __ ] in my way aren't
you
you've got fights i'll give you that
ethan
but what's the plan when you have all
four flasks
what are you trying to get at i could
lend you a hand
not trying to get on my good side i
don't get cocky
i'd kill you if you weren't worth the
trouble
there's a stronghold not too far outside
the village
go there and get my flask do that
and you pass first head back to the
graveyard
why does this guy talk like a serious
neck beard does anybody else pick that
up
go and get in my flask but like not
quite oh what the hell is that
a cadoo is that
alive uh okay very gross
well i'm just gonna keep looking at it
apparently
and now i'm done great
cool go and get my flask
i guess i'm out of here then great
key system you know really good keys
really
whoever planned this out really elegant
stuff
oh okay that's the window that's
probably fine oh i finally get to save i
feel like i haven't even seen a
typewriter in ages
yeah when is the lesson oh my god there
probably was a typewriter and i just
didn't see it but also
that feels like it was a long time oh
castle
look babe look it's your castle
no no no look
look at your castle look look honey
look pumpkin look sugar lump
it's your castle where the hell am i
gonna get these balls where do these
balls come from
i feel like i feel like you know the
game this game i really
[Music]
please
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i wanted to shoot you it's too late
now i'll never get another opportunity
where am i going also this is even where
i'm supposed to go
oh no
who where who what am i blind
i'm blind i have no idea they're
probably in the ground again oh
yeah that's fine
who are they bothering nobody
can i help you oh my god who the okay
you're gonna get a face full of a lot
you're gonna get a face full of this
boom
really really really
well let's dance [ __ ] and dance that's
what i thought
that is in fact what i thought oh [ __ ]
hello that's a big pile of meat
the duke could love that you have one
stuck in a freaking
you stop doing the weird divy things
they don't like you guys
at least they could give good money not
that i need it
money seems to be okay
there we go yeah money is uh not in
short supply
didn't get everything in there yes i did
also where am i going
i don't even know where the graveyard is
let alone how to get back to it so if
someone could point me in the right
direction
be greatly appreciated someone in the
outhouse
someone inside hello
hey this is really cool and all but uh i
needed whatever you were munching on
hey what's up
oh yeah you almost got me with that one
oh yeah real close good fight
mother miranda gave me a mountain now i
can do lots and lots of caddo
experiments this is my
secret special laboratory i did three
caddo experiments today
but they all went pop and made a mess i
put in the caddo and then i tried
putting some wolf blood from a needle
into the spine
the person wriggled a lot and then
killed my assistant i could not hold it
down so i put it in a cage
now i have to feed it put a brush
there is space my friend there is most
certainly space
thank you
i gotta be careful with this thing i
gotta make sure i hit my shots
you know the knife is really useless i
really wish i had a better knife
i would love a better knife absolutely
love a better knife maybe i was supposed
to get here first
was i supposed to come oh maybe i was
supposed to come up here first
oh hey bud uh by the way
have one of these hey what's up dude
come here
come here come here yeah come here
oh you're so stupid you're
so freaking dumb oh [ __ ] you're left
uh have one of these hey come on
what's up bud oh yeah
oh you're so freaking dumb oh
okay i was supposed to shoot there hey
uh stop
okay that's yeah okay we've all had our
fun
without our fun let me sploosh a little
goose on my guts that you've exposed and
um
[Music]
let's try this thing let's try it let's
try this have some fun let's have some
fun my dude
you better come around this corner you
better not be going to the left
oh [ __ ] you're dead
all right good good fight man good fight
really good fight you really almost got
me there
hello oh
um i can go back and do the ball thing
i can get a super skull for more money
which i don't need
but i can do it oh you know actually i
wouldn't have been able to come over
here because it was a crank thing to get
this
over fascinating okay whoa easy they're
easy they're easy they're easy easy
whoa whoa easy
take it easy take it easy easy
let's not get out of ourselves let's not
get ahead of ourselves come on
easy easy okay okay
oh careful careful
okay okay whoa easy easy easy
where are we where are we whoa easy
okay okay okay
uh thanks for this wow this is
chartreuse
i love chartreuse whatever it is
that's great thank you all right goodbye
i'm gonna go see the duke now and i'm
gonna sell him a bunch of useless
crystals
i don't know what he's doing with the
crystals and frankly i don't care
this way
oh thank you thank you very much
i like this guy you know this guy
heisenberg i kind of like him
i think he's a pretty cool dude i gotta
go kill some chickens
i wish i hadn't sold that fish that i
got it first i didn't know
tried not to but whatever you know
sometimes you do sometimes you don't
this is a lot to just get to some
chickens
that was a lot of work to open up a gate
for some
chickens thank you
thank you it's gonna be delicious meal
is there no other chicken here
is the sound houses open
i guess that's all of them also what's
this
is going to give me the other ball i
need where am i
where am i hello where the hell am i
where am i why am i here
okay all right i got what i needed
apparently
this way papa oh you know my nickname
hey the gate is open
oh oh
rose is waiting for me all right well
i'll be right there rose
uh-huh sure thing yeah no problem
hey duke man hey big man pop duke what
are you looking at what the freak how'd
you get that
ah my apologies
uh-huh your apologies about what
you want crystals crystal beast chris no
crystal moreau
absolutely take that jesus
looks like it can be inserted into
something
all right and we are pretty much set
except i'm also going to sell the limi
because i now have the other thing
celluli
i don't know how to detach let me let me
see if i can detach the stuff first this
is lord moroes i suppose it's what they
call
the beauty of the grotesque i suppose
man say whatever you want about it i
have no idea
i really cannot take that off
all right fine then what do you have oh
let's beef this up a bit
oh yeah uh let's see what else we got
first um
oh yeah oh yeah
i saw you eyeing that one oh yeah
okay goodbye lemmy goodbye lemmy
surprise you'd
so early so early for what early for
what my dude okay first off yes
[Music]
i really don't need this thing but at
the same
time i'll get them congratulations with
this you'll not worry about missing
anything
well i wasn't exactly struggling so all
right
now i have that i've got the final key
what's this for oh the flask you know
i'm not just gonna put the flasks there
i'm not just gonna do that i'm gonna go
up here
wait back to the graveyard
that's what i was instructed to do and
someone called me papa am i still
rolling hell yeah i am who called me
papa who the hell
tried to call me papa it's daddy
and you'll get it right rose is waiting
for you okay fine
why'd you put up all this oh because he
has he's
[Music]
i like my meat tender
in the jungle where
i hear you
okay you live this time [ __ ]
but next time you're gonna get it you're
gonna get
real good okay i have not been this way
i suppose
oh look at that i didn't even know this
gate was here unless i did
which if i did i'm gonna pretend like i
didn't
good luck well this seems familiar
wasn't there a situation in uh
re7 where there's something like this oh
well hmm any fish in here
fish fisherms
fisherloos fishelonis i'm not going to
blow these up because i'm imagining i'm
i'm going to need them to blow something
up that's not me if that made sense oh
hey
what's up bam still don't know what
that's about but
it is what it is i mean i know exactly
what that's about no one needs to tell
me
oh my god stop commenting i know what
it's about
it's like the bobble heads from the
other game i know
i know
give people something way
too far with it hey you like knife
i shouldn't waste my shotgun with you
try me try me you'll never win
[Music]
stab poke joke
and you're dead all right is that
everything here
seems like there's some kind of a
treasure
hello something tells me i'm going in
the back way to this
hi oh
i feel like i'm ruining a big surprise
i really do i feel like i'm kind of rude
like i feel okay so
hear me out here right hear me out
clearly they set
something up oh hey oh okay
clearly they set up something really
nice for me
and and i'm going around the back way
for it
that's that's just so uncool of me
you know what i mean like what kind of
[ __ ] am i that i'm gonna
like look the good luck it's clearly oh
it's probably dope as hell ah reminds me
of the adventure express i'm gonna leave
this one up to you
which way do i go i don't know if one
matters over the other but it sure seems
like one is the back way and it seems
like it's going to ruin the experience
and i don't want to ruin the experience
so i'm going to leave it up to you
you guys decide and whatever you decide
i will do in the meantime actually i
just saw there was a well on the map and
holy [ __ ]
anyway i'm gonna go check out this well
but you get your comment fingers typing
and you tell me exactly what i'm
supposed to do because i can't make a
decision for myself to save my life
and it might ooh necklace with
two holes
are you
i sold
lady dimitriscu would have loved this
but i sold
a i sold something
very nice if i needed that i'm gonna be
very upset
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching comment which way i
should go in the description or comments
down below and i'll read it
probably i'll read it thank you and as
always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye